Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
You got a friend and me. Yeah.
You got a friend and me I'm Wendy Newman.
Hello everyone.
We'll come back to comics explained, Oh, we are covering venom. Yes,
we are. The, the,
the follow-up to what it is that directly happened to Eddie Brock. Right?
Because in the last video that we did,
I'll let you guys on like this one soon cliffhanger, right?
And like Ben died and Eddie Brock has dead wood. That being said, guys,
I'm just bounced. And you guys were like, no, it was kind of amazing.
But uh, in this video we find that what actually happened to Eddie Brock, right?
So the cool thing about this is we would largely assume that Eddie Brock had
died, but the, the way that Donnie Cates plays us as amazing.
And this is why Donnie Casey, this is why I'm really,
really liking Donnie Cates when he first took over venom.
And even when he wrote banjos and things like that,
it was kind of hard to get a gauge of what kind of writer Donnie Cates was.
You knew he was a great writer,
but you didn't know the nuances behind his writing style.
And what we're kind of learning here is Donnie Cates is almost kind of like this
perfect blend between like Jonathan Hickman and Scott Snyder and Jeff Johns,
where he plants these little seeds,
these little tidbits of things that might become important later on,
I may actually do. Right? So in this instance, Eddie Brock,
when his body basically dies, right?
When he's effectively killed that he just kind of comes falling down into this
place called the abyss. Right now,
this happens immediately it's as soon as he hits the vehicle. Right?
So this is before he dies at the end of the last video that he was technically
quote, unquote dead before that happened,
that his body just kind of fallen into this, this sort of underbelly, right.
This sort of abyss. And he kind of talks about these things, right? Like,
you know, he's fallen before and there's only darkness and things like that,
that he can see his physical form, you know,
that it's kind of in the world above him,
but it's almost like on a spiritual level,
he's kind of losing himself and Donnie Cates almost kind of plays a fast and
loose with the idea of like, what happens when a person dies,
because Marvel doesn't really give us any sort of consistent explanation on
that, right? Like if you go and you read the old Chris Claremont X-Men stories,
for example,
you get a depiction of what the realm of mistress death actually looks like.
Right? Worst, basically just all these really, really tall pillars.
And each one represents somebody's afterlife.
But then you have like the realm of a Vista where you have, you know,
one of the versions of health that's basically kept by the various held Lords.
And then you have like the realm of Hela, right.
Which is called hell in and of itself, you know,
and that's where people who are dead go and you have all these different
indications and depictions of, of like where the soul goes when a person dies.
But for Eddie here, you know, in the midst of this place that he's in,
it's not really recognizable to him,
but did he kind of hears this disembodied voice? And it's just like Brock,
right. It's just, you know, and it just literally jars him, right. Like that.
And he's just like wake up and it's really cool, you know?
And he addresses him as like a soldier. He's like wake up soldier, you know?
And he's like NOLs minions. Like they have human. Like,
and this is when it was really given to us where we end up finding out that
where he's at right now is he's part of the hive. Right?
He's part of the collective hive of know the Symbian God that yes,
his physical body is dead, but his essence has kind of moved on.
And there's a reason why this happens. And it's really, really cool.
But you know,
one of the things that this disembodied voice basically tells them is if you're
going to move, right. If like what you need to do here to make yourself stop,
right? Like if you're going to break out of this hive where at least try to,
you know,
maintain your sanity in this hive and keep from being consumed by like all the
symbionts, you know, basically know himself,
then you have to maintain your own self.
And the only way to do that is to stop yourself from falling.
And the only way to stop yourself from falling is to brace for impact and lamp.
And that's exactly what he does. Or he does a superhero landing right here.
He does the superhero landing, and then suddenly he's met by a guy.
He doesn't recognize. Now, if you're, if you're familiar with Dani cases,
venom run, you do know who this guy is. Right.
And it took me a minute to remember, I was like, who in the heck of this?
And I was like, that's right. And it turns out to be ref Strickland right now,
Rick Strickland, the gods were a little fuzzy here on his character.
Direct Strickland was one of the guys who was kind of bonded to have been
Abyssinia during the days of the Vietnam war. I think it was the Vietnam war,
but he was basically one of the first people in the history of the world to be
bonded with a venom semi. He only had it for a few years.
And then ultimately Rick Strickland ended up dying as far as I'm aware.
And instead his Symbion basically replicated it. Right. It took its place.
The rest of Strickland's team ended up dying,
but all that was kind of lead up to the notion or the introduction of the idea
of the Grendel and like Knoll and all that kind of stuff. Oh,
we've got videos on it. If you guys want to go check it all out,
kind of get yourself fully refreshed on the nature of the character.
But what he basically says here, where,
where Eddie Brock had of asked the question, like, why am I here? Right?
Because he sees like a handful of people running any jumps in to try to save
them, but they're like ghosts, right.
He literally just passes right through them. He can't really touch them.
He can't interact with them. So it was really more him. That's the ghost.
And there's even like a giant dragon that comes like flying down and seems to
know that Eddie's there, right.
And Eddie light goes to attack it and look what he was going to do by punching a
dragon for the dragon, just kind of flies, right.
It just kind of blows right through them. And almost kind of,
it gives them the feeling that like he's being ripped apart.
And so what he ends up doing, or at least what he's told by, uh,
by record is that the reason why he's in this place is because of the codex.
Because if you got to remember that,
one of the things that Donnie Cates established is that every time a symbiont
bonds itself to a host, that when the, it leaves that host,
it leaves behind a kind of codex inside that host.
And so what this is to make this a lot easier to understand,
this is just one small aspect of Eddie Brock's consciousness, essentially,
right? If you could break his consciousness down to like a,
an almost biotechnological well organism, it would be the codex.
And that's where it is now, right?
His consciousness has been absorbed into Knoll by virtue of the codex,
because he was a Symbian at one point in time.
And it's one of these things where it almost seems to point to this idea that
whenever a person who is a host for a Simeon dies,
that they almost kind of joined this black abyss, right. It's almost like the,
the afterlife, like were speedsters joined the speed force.
This is where Simeon hosts go. Now it's not absolute,
it's not concrete because we see people here who have basically been absorbed by
Knoll when they were consumed by symbionts.
But it all almost kind of lends credence to it, right?
It's not like somebody out there shot in the head and some bugging gone wrong.
And then now they're part of, right, like every single person that you see here,
every single body that you see is a person who was contacted with a syndicate
and then absorbed into no. Well, the question becomes if that's the case,
if Reggie Strickland is here because of his shred of consciousness,
surviving through the codex and being absorbed by Knoll.
And if Eddie Brock is here, because his portion of his consciousness was,
was absorbed to the codex and, and now as part of no,
then why isn't anybody else moving around and talking, right?
Why are they the only ones who were really aware of what's going on?
And everybody else just looks like characters out of the matrix.
The reason why is because of the fact that they had been bonded with symbions
for so long, their connection is stronger than everybody.
Else's the one thing to keep in mind here,
everybody here that you see strung up, right? Ben Grimm, captain America,
vision,
all these different characters that they were bonded with symbionts for moments,
right? Like it was literally seconds.
Or if they were bottled with the Symbion over the course of their publication
history, it was only for like a single event, right.
Or for a few moments in time.
Whereas Rick Strickland had SMB it for years and Eddie Brock had his tibia for a
year still. Right. For, for even longer than that.
And so it's kind of a crazy thing where, you know,
where Eddie doesn't fully grasp the reality of what's going on,
that this kind of realm that they're in is almost a mirror.
They're almost really in the real world.
But the reality is it's almost like an illusion, right?
It's almost like a mirror of the real world.
They can't really react with anything. They can't really touch anything.
They can just kind of exist in that place. And that's it.
They just sort of exist and they stay there and there really doesn't seem to be
any true escape. And it's one of the things that Eddie kind of asks,
well then like, why can't I go back to the real world? Right? I mean,
if my consciousness is alive here,
then why can't I simply just leave this place and go back? And he's like,
do you not know? Like you do, you are, you he's like, dude, you don't know.
And he's like, Eddie brought you're dead, man.
Like you're literally laying dead on a hospital bed and like your kids crying
over you like, and, and it's one of the things where Eddie freaks, right?
Eddie absolutely freaks out when he, when he hears that.
And this is one of the cool things, right?
This is one of the best things about this as Donnie Cates.
I'm going to say this. I don't care what anybody out there says,
Donny Kate's handling a venom is probably the single best handling of the venom
character in the history of Marvel comics. Right.
And I don't really even believe there's anybody who can argue that point
adequately.
Like they might be able to make a couple of good points here and there,
but nobody could actually maintain that point for the long haul.
And so they actually, age of Venom's run was much better. Know this,
this one is far more complex is a lot more nuanced agent. Bynum's great,
but it's Johnny cage venom run, right? It's just not on the same level.
It's kind of crazy here because what you end up getting is,
is Eddie Brock just kind of freaking out and saying like over the course of my
whole life, I've had to gift things up. I've lost things.
I've had things taken from me.
Like I'm literally a man of sacrifice and loss and I'm not going to let them
take this. Right? Like I'm not going to let them take my death.
Like if I'm going to die, it's going to be on my terms. And so his whole,
his whole idea here is okay, if we can walk around inside this void, right?
This, uh, bits, this living of best where no rain Supreme, then if I'm here,
that means my symbionts here. So it's like,
I'm going to find myself Simeon and working together.
We can bust out of this place. Right.
We can literally break away from the hive mind and just kind of show up.
Now the reality,
and this is one of the big differences here until Eddie Brock's consciousness
merges with his physical body, it would basically be as consciousness, hitching,
a ride alongside the Symbian, the CME, it would appear.
And it would look like Eddie, but it wouldn't really be as physical form,
assuming that even happens.
And the reason why I say assuming is because rec says, okay, like,
I believe he won this man. And I believe that you can do it, right. I mean,
you're a hard hitting guy. I kinda misjudged you a little bit,
but here's the problem that you have finding your Symbion is not going to be the
problem, getting to it and freeing it. That's the problem.
Because we find out that when Knoll took a Simeot of Eddie, when he took the,
took the, the actual venom Simeon, he didn't just disperse it among the,
you know, everything else in the Fs. Instead he keeps it close.
He holds onto it. Right.
So Eddie's literally gonna have to find a way to get to know and then steal his
symbiont back. And that's when he's kind of like, okay, well, I mean,
how am I supposed to get up there by, uh, by myself and the response of,
of Rex's none enough. You don't have to do it by yourself, man. Right?
You don't have to do it by yourself. I'm going to go with you.
But here's the more important thing. Yes. I recruited you for this mission in,
uh, you know, to help me go back and take these. Symbionts like, yes,
I recruited you as a kind of agent, you know, that's what I wanted you to be.
But the reality is that you were not an agent, Eddie Brock,
you were never really an agent. You know,
you were a guy who came across a Symbi at one day and did some things and,
and you've been bonded with her for a long time,
but you were not the kind of man I was looking for. Fortunately,
inside this place,
I did find the man that I was looking for only for us to find out that that
agent venom flash Thompson has returned without being said, guys,
we're going to bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain,
make sure you guys are the sub button to become part of the Rob core.
If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop like,
and I will catch you all later.